[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Daniel Mattingly he is an assistant
professor of political science at Yale
who studies the political economy of
development and authoritarian politics
with a focus on China his current work
examines the role of the military
nationalism and surveillance technology
in Chinese politics today we'll talk
with professor Mattingly about his new
book the art of political control in
China
welcome professor Mattingly thank you so
much for having me so let's begin with
an overview of your book tell us about
it
absolutely so my book looks at the sort
of hidden side of political control in
China so what motivates the book is an
interest in in understanding China and
China's rise which i think is one of the
most interesting exciting stories of the
21st century so you have in China a
country where over 800 million people
have lifted themselves out of
dollar-a-day poverty into the global
middle class and at the same time you
have state that's implemented these
ambitious far-reaching policies of
social control and social engineering so
I think an example that most people need
nighted states would be familiar with is
the one-child policy which limited the
number of children that people could
have but they're then also a number of
other policies especially policies
around property rights and lands that
have also sort of deeply we reached
deeply into into society and changed it
so that the question that I'm interested
in with the book is how has the state
implemented these ambitious far-reaching
policies of social engineering while at
the same time controlling protests and
the basic answer that I have on the book
is that it's not just about the police
so I think in the West often when we
think about authoritarian regimes we
have this image of authoritarian regimes
controlling society through the police
and through coercion that certainly
happens in China so I think an important
example China is what's happening in the
western part of China and the
Jinzhong which is a region of China
that's inhabited by Weaver's a Muslim
ethnic minority and over a million
people have been sent to re-education
camps and Shinjo an extremely kind of
coercive policy so there's been some
good reporting on this and the New York
Times and other outlets so my research
so that certainly happens and
authoritarian regimes include China my
research though focuses on this more
sort of hidden tools that the state uses
even in places like Shindong but
certainly throughout China to control
society so the surprising thing that I
find in my book is that civil society
groups local grassroots social
organizations are great tools for the
state to influence control and monitor
society so grassroots social
organizations that in other contexts we
might think are useful for organizing
and holding leaders accountable are in
authoritarian contexts like China
actually quite useful for the state to
implement policies like the one-child
policy or land requisitions
while maintaining political stability
okay and so we will unpack all of that
in a minute but I am curious to know
what led you to be interested in this
absolutely so I so I was a Yale
undergrad back in the day and after I
graduated from Yale I went and and lived
in China so if there are young
undergrads watching I guess there are
some great programs at Yale to go study
and and live in China after you graduate
so I took advantage of some of these
programs well as an undergrad at Yale
lived in China and I think and when I
was in China starting in the mid 2000s
where were you I was in Hunan Province
which is sort of in the south eastern
south western part of China so it's kind
of sort of if you overlaid China on the
United States or Arkansas why did you go
there so I did a program actually
through Princeton called Princeton and
Asia that sent me that sent me to Hunan
Province Yale the yellow tribe
Association also has a great program
that sends teachers to the same province
to teach so I just happened to be sent
to that province which is a great sort
of fascinating introduction to China
this is a part of China that was
developing really rapidly when I went
there so I mean I think so some of my
good friends whose
even a generation ago you know their
parents weren't able to have meat every
week because you know not just because
of the great report but because it was a
relatively poor area of China by the
time I was there in the mid two
thousands not only were they putting
bacon on the table every day but by
people were starting to buy cars I had
nice apartments and we're starting to
enter enter the middle class so seeing
this was sort of fascinating but on the
other hand just down the road there were
people who as part of these local state
led development projects people who are
being forced in their land and worked
very happy about it so you know China I
think like the United States is a big
country full of contradictions and so
sort of seeing on the one hand this
rapid development which is really what's
behind the rise of China on the world
stage and on the other hands people who
were in this case trying to fight for
their land fight for their property and
was something that fascinated me and so
that sort of leads directly into this
book project and understanding the roots
of political control and how did you do
the research for the book so for the
book I went and did field research in a
number of villages in China so it's
involved partly going in and living
there again in an area or a different
part of China so I did go to I did go to
Hunan Province as for part of my
research and also spent some time in
Guangdong Province jeongsu and Ankara
and so I went to four different
provinces but most of my research was
focused in the southern province of
Guangdong which is next to next to Hong
Kong actually next include on but I did
I did go back to who went on to do it to
do research so I so I took a multi
method approach so I did a couple of
things first I went to and stayed for a
while and interview people in some of
these villages to try to understand how
the process of local development and
land requisition happened especially
interested and land rights and how
farmers and the rural poor can ensure
that they have access to land that's
theirs and if the state decides to
requisition and redevelop it that they
can get good compensation and just
should try to understand the politics of
these village and what
what causes people to mobilize are not
mobilize in in protests so I combined
this two sort of boots on the ground I
guess almost ethnographic approach with
collecting data so I also did survey
research across a number of villages in
China so kind of using this quantitative
data and the qualitative data I was able
to triangulate on an answer for how it
is that the state has been able to
requisition land and implement the
one-child policy without encountering a
widespread protest in all cases okay so
what did you determine how are they able
to do that I'm particularly interested
in the one-child rule and is is that so
in existence today I thought I had read
that it's that it's not but it is no so
so the Chinese family planning policies
have been modified so you know was never
it's called a one-child policy in in the
West but it was first of all in China it
was never a blanket one-child policies
exceptions policies are different in
different provinces and even to a
certain extent different in different
counties and there are exceptions carved
out for people who are I think
minorities or people who in some cases
if you have a daughter as your first
child you might be able to have a second
child especially if you live in a rural
part of China so yeah so the one-child
policy I mean I think is in many ways
maybe an emblem in the west of social
engineering and social control right in
an authoritarian regime like China and I
think in I mean it's it's an interesting
policy because I think and a lot of
urban China it has a lot of political
legitimacy I think a lot of people would
probably have willingly only had one
child anyway and people I think so these
are people and some sense saw the need
for it it's a much less popular policy
in rural China partly for economic
reasons it's just more useful to have
more children or if you're farming or
you need to send children to cities to
work and then remit your wages back home
so it's it's a much less popular in
rural China policy in rural China which
is when I was focusing on so the kind of
puzzle there is why do people why do
people in rural trying to comply with
this anyway and so one answer to this is
is coercion but and about another piece
to this which is the piece that I
explore which I
I think social scientists have thought
about less is the non-coercive side of
it which is the way that the state uses
social organizations to try to influence
them okay and let's talk about that how
do they use those things what are some
of the strategies that they employ to
kind of covertly control the people so I
talked about three different strategies
in my book the first is using local
source social organizations especially
local civil society organizations as a
direct tool of social controls okay tell
us what a civil group is so the sorts of
civil society groups that I look at in
my projects are mostly rural social
organizations so you could think of
temple associations folk religious
organizations that might that have local
temple groups lineage associations these
are kinship networks that might create a
local Association and have an ancestral
hall with ancestral tablets to venerate
and celebrate their ancestors also more
kind of sort of traditional folk music
groups are another kind of social
organization all right so it sounds like
a very die group a diverse group so how
do they tap those organizations to kind
of manipulate what they what they want
to happen so there are a few different
ways and it's not completely I don't
want to paint the picture that is
completely insidious process process a
lot of times where these are
organizations that people of course are
genuinely interested in an interest in
starting so especially so China in the
50s 60s and 70s when Mao Zedong was in
power abolish a lot of these groups and
tried to get rid of them they sort of
reconstituted or revived starting in the
1980s and even though China as a
communist country is sort of nominally
or at least tries to discourage religion
and some of these local civic
organizations however as I think in the
80s when these groups and 90s when these
groups were getting started again local
officials often saw them as useful for
because the existence of this local
group meant two things one if you have
members of these groups it's a little
bit easier to to monitor them and see
what's going on so if you have people
regularly coming and going to one of
these temples or ancestral halls it just
makes them a little bit easier to
monitor I think it's also especially
useful because these groups up and have
leaders who then have social influence
and this informal social influence is
really useful for officials when they
want to implement policy so if you want
to convince somebody and they should
comply with a one-child policy you're
going to convince somebody that they
should move off their land so the
village can build a new factory it's
useful to have these socially
influential allies who can help persuade
you to move people off their lands so I
think it's it's more process of sort of
allowing these groups to to flourish as
they're useful describe how the groups
are actually I'm curious to know like
does the [ __ ] does the government
contact one person in the group and says
hey you know we kind of want it this or
that to happen I mean how does the
process actually work I'm curious the
very nitty-gritty of that they need
agree but so so it's often a kind of
organic an organic process that's that
happens over time so you can have you
you might have in a village the leader
for example of a local lineage group
again these are kind of extended kinship
networks so you can think of as
essentially clans and the leader of this
kinship group might event someone who
sort of emerged over time is just
somebody who was unusually competence
and authoritative mm-hmm someone taking
whom others and the group would go to
sort of ask for advice to try to get a
job to sort of ask what though what's
the right social etiquette for putting
on a wedding you know how many pounds of
rice do I need to bring to the bride and
so you in a lot of villages and you have
somebody who is maybe the kind of
informal or de-facto leader of this of
this kinship network once that person
emerges it's it's can be kind of a kind
of natural process than for local
political leaders like the Communist
Party secretary of the village is sort
of the most powerful political figure in
a village in China for this person to
seek out their socially influential
person and say well listen I need to we
to take
land from the following five farmers who
are in your who are in your clan or
because we need to build a road or
because we need to put in a you know a
power transformer or eminent domain in
this country exactly it's like eminent
domain you have to get people to
actually reply with and especially if
you're not offering compensation at at
market rate we're definitely what
happens or what happens in a lot of
these cases especially in the world
China okay so so it's useful to have
these local elites as social as allies
for the state to help to help implement
these policies and a more kind of direct
oh go ahead and then would it be an
honor for the people who comply with the
request I mean culturally how would they
be looked upon by the rest of the the
group well I think that in general the
reason it's useful to have these allies
is because they do have social Authority
so I'm not sure it's exactly I'm not
sure it's an honor but I think there is
a kind of social obligation that comes
with being a member of these social
groups that means that you need to
listen to the people who have power and
I think this of course this isn't
something that's specific or strange or
unique to to China or to how lineage
groups or temple groups or neighborhood
associations are organized in China I
mean you could think of you know
politically or socially influential
people in your own neighborhood who
might be you know they could be priests
or you know rabbis or just somebody who
has become a kind of neighborhood leader
because they're if they're charismatic
and energetic and there's a certain
amount of social pressure I think to
listen to listen to people in these
positions of social Authority so I'm
sort of looking at what's often the kind
of the flipside of these social groups I
think in academia we often think about
civil society as beneficial to democracy
and I think that there that that can
that can be the case these organizations
can be used you know to mobilize people
to hold political leaders accountable
when they don't behave well the flipside
of that to that though is that these
social groups can also be useful for
political leaders when they want to get
something done that doesn't always
benefit local society mmm-hmm so what
happens when local society doesn't want
to do what something what someone has
suggested that they do
one of these political leaders or the
leader of the civil society so the flip
side to this is that that I argue that
places that don't have strong civil
society groups or don't have strong what
I call infiltrating organizations which
are more direct organizations actually
set up by the Communist Party so party
sells small groups which are sort of the
equivalent of like a neighborhood watch
group which is directly controlled and
set up by the party these are also very
useful direct mechanisms of control
through grassroots organizations the
flip side to this is when these
organizations don't exist it's actually
almost paradoxically easier for social
groups to organize so in the acts sort
of absence of civil society it's easier
to get leaderless protest so this is
something that I saw in a number of
villages to people who were for example
unhappy with their lands being
requisitioned by the state and they
weren't getting very good compensation
they didn't feel like in the long run
this is a good deal for them they wanted
to hold on to the land that had been you
know in their family for in some cases
over a dozen generations so what did
they do they didn't have a local sort of
civil society lineage Association that
would help them organize so instead they
turned to sort of leaderless quasi
leaderless methods of political
organization so such as what so in the
case of one village they a small group
of villagers basically anonymously hung
up posters all over the village saying
okay let's all we're all unhappy they
sort of took the temperature for but he
knew that everybody was unhappy and hung
posters up around the village telling
people okay we're going to be here at at
the village square at a certain time on
a certain day to put pressure on local
leaders and protest and protest against
this protest against his land
requisition and how does that work I
mean what was the outcome so the outcome
was they got to keep their land because
basically enough of the people in the
village mobilized I think something like
eighty percent of the village actually
ended up coming out to the square even
though there wasn't there wasn't a kind
of clear leader this protest was just
some anonymous citizen or group of
citizens who was putting these posters
up around the village enough people came
out that higher levels of local
government to
notice and saw what was going on in this
village and ended up halting halting the
land requisition so people were able to
get what they want by mobilizing but it
was helpful to to use this tactic of
leaderless protest okay so I guess my
next question would be were those people
fearful that there would be any
retribution by the government for coming
out and basically saying that they were
against what was happening well I think
there's power and there's power in
numbers and I think that they would have
legitimately been fearful if there were
a small number of people who are the
clear leaders of this protest and that
does happen where it's there are leaders
of the protests it's possible to
identify who they are and then they face
pressure the pressure could either be
pressure from their family members who
might have jobs government jobs and are
threatened to lose their be threatened
to lose their jobs if they don't
pressure their own family to stand down
or of course they might be jailed or
beaten by the police if there are clear
leaders of the protest if it's a
leaderless there are no leaders that are
going to put in jail and if you have 80
percent of 80 percent of a town coming
out to protest it's the government going
to jail 80 percent of the people in the
town
clearly not so it forces it to certain
extent it can force local governments to
make concessions okay so let's talk
about what's going on in Hong Kong for
the past six months what's your take on
that situation so the dynamics in Hong
Kong are I mean there I think there's
some interesting similarities to what
happens in mainland China of course
they're important differences but the so
the important differences really briefly
Hong Kong has been a sort of it's been a
special administrative region of China
since since 1997 after the handover from
from the British and so Hong Kong has
been guaranteed certain protections
under the one country two systems policy
especially greater civil liberty
liberties then then exist in the
mainland so I think though the protest
was originally motivated by a desire to
try to hold on to these civil liberties
so the Hong Kong government had proposed
an extradition law that people were
worried would that allow the
government in the mainland to then
extradite people who spoke out against
it so that was as those sort of what
drove what drove these protests I think
one of the interesting things is the
tactics used by the protesters and the
tactics used by the government are quite
similar to what happens in the mainland
so on the protesters side one of the
reasons why these protests have
succeeded is precisely they've they've
adopted this leaderless protest model
that I described to you as happens in
the mainland and Hong Kong it's a much
more hi-tech model then going and sort
of putting up posters around the village
they're using encrypted social media
apps right like telegram to to organize
and decide where the protests decide
what tactics to use protesters are also
using online forums to do this and it's
partly partly a reaction against what
happened to an earlier wave of protests
in 2014 when there were when there were
clear leaders of this protest and then
the state the state targeted them as
often happens there's nothing happens in
the mainland so how's the government
responded well so one of the tactics I
mean obviously the most important thing
the government has responded to use
outright coercion a ton of tear gas
rubber bullets and and arrests at the
same time the government's also tried to
use social organisations as a way to
mobilize pro-government Pro mainland
support in a way that I think echoes
what happens with these civil society
groups in the mainland so in Hong Kong
these groups are one type of group that
has on this our native place
associations so these are people who
have moved to Hong Kong or their
ancestors maybe a generation or two
before have moved to Hong Kong from a
place in mainland China like Fujian and
then they set up associations just with
clubs right for for people to organize
and and the government to some extent
has used these associations to mobilize
people against against the pro-democracy
protesters and in support of of the
mainland government so this is a kind of
inversion of what you usually think of
as you have a robust civil society the
civil society is going to strengthen
democracy in this case at least one
elements of Hong Kong civil society is
being used to organize in support of the
government and against these
pro-democracy protesters okay so what do
you
do you think the future hulls for the
protesters what you think will end up
happening that's a good question I mean
there's no way to know there's no way
just wondering if you have any ideas
well I think that the protests in some
ways have been quite have been
tactically innovative so there's been on
the on the negative side there's been
violence and I think you know violence
against people which is which you can't
really excuse and violence targeting
people from the mainland I think there's
also there's also about a lot of
property damage which i think is you
know ethically different I mean I think
stills maybe not something that's
certainly in the West in the tradition
of non-violent protests that people
would would advocate for but I think is
at least distinct from violence against
people but I think the great the great
mass of protesters aren't violent
towards people and aren't are an
extremists and their desire is basically
for to protect the civil liberties that
they have so they've adopted these
innovative tactics that's where
leaderless protests using these apps and
some more sorts of innovative
cooperative tactics on the grounds it
was the kind of model one of the mottos
of the protest is be like water so the
idea said they're protesters kind of
shift around so that the police can't
surround them and kettle them and arrest
them I think though that this the these
sorts of tactical innovations which have
worked to sustain this protest for a
long time so the protests have going up
been going on for four months now I mean
outlasted the 2014 umbrella movement is
outlasted by revolution and he of Egypt
has outlasted the 1989 movements in in
mainland China but strategically it's
not clear to me where these protests are
going and whether or not I think that
the protesters have succeeded in pushing
back and and wringing concessions from
the governments the government withdrew
the extradition law that I talked about
earlier which is the original impetus
from the protesters if they withdrew
that why are they still protesting so
the protesters actually a five have five
demands and so the government has has
essentially met one of them but they did
have kind of very they did it in sort of
slow motion in a way that I think didn't
really satisfy very many people and so
some of the other two
it's like a demand for an inquiry into
police violence which i think is a
demand that Beijing could potentially
could potentially meet if they wanted to
the resignation of the chief executive
you get is something that could
potentially could potentially happen
amnesty for for all of the for the
protesters who've been arrested which i
think is probably politically more
difficult for Beijing and so I think
that the the fact that the government's
hasn't met these other demands and
especially the fact that the amount of
teargas used a matter of rubber bullets
using the number of arrests has
mobilized
I think surprisingly the rest of Hong
Kong to support these young protesters
so the the frontline protesters are a
lot of young people or college aged or
sometimes even younger maybe you know
into their mid-20s the surprising thing
is that this protests despite the
violence maintains high levels of
support among the Hong Kong middle class
we see this in surveys see this in the
results of elections that were held
recently which the pro-democracy camp
won pretty resounding lean a big
reversal for for Beijing so the fact
that they continue to have this support
among a relatively broad swath of the
Hong Kong population means that I think
will probably continue to see some level
of mobilization I think if the
government was continue to make
concessions that might slowly you might
see a slow fading away mm-hmm
interesting so what would you like your
readers to take away from your book so a
couple I think to two main things to
take away from the book I think the
first is that when we think about how
governments control societies we often
think just about outright violence and
coercion or sometimes we think also
about the ways in which governments
generate legitimacy so in the United
States and democracies there's a lot of
theory around how the democratic process
generates legitimacy so people think
that the government's laws and policies
are just and then comply with them I
think that there's a whole range of
tactics the government's use in between
this that are neither quite about
legitimacy and are nor are they violent
coercion that are more sort of hidden
forms of a coercion that get people to
comply with the state
so that's the sort of mean kind of
theoretical takeaway I mean I think also
in the bigger picture I think the book
one of the things that I think I hope
people take away from the book is that I
think it's a it's also a hopeful book
and a lot of ways I think it hopefully
tells the story of a lot of people who
are able to get what they want from
their governments in part by organizing
under quite difficult quite difficult
circumstances so in the long run so I'm
I'm a China optimist in both in
especially especially in the long run
and I hope that some of that some of the
optimism comes out in the book okay well
this has been fascinating thank you so
much for being here and sharing some of
your work okay thank you for having me
for more information about Professor
Mattingly and his research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us for another episode
of the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you